the full-length trailer for the third
season of stranger things has finally
arrived showing our young heroes gearing
up for what should be one of the most
memorable summers of their lives and it
probably will be just not for the
reasons they may have hoped stranger
things 3 takes place roughly six months
after the events of the second season
the trailer opens with the gang
welcoming Dustin home from camp by way
of a little 11 assisted prank the
trailer doesn't outright say what year
the third season is set in instead
cluing us in to what time it is with
Motley Crue's 1985 hit home sweet home
playing on Dustin's boombox you can also
see the current year on Dustin's hat the
name of the camp Dustin's returning from
Camp Nowhere seems like it might be a
reference to a location in the guardians
of the galaxy a franchise with its own
nostalgic ties to the 80s from a
writer-director who's made his fair
share of slimy stranger things as
Creature Features joining the cast for
season 3 is Cary Elwes who would hold a
special place in the hearts of certain
film fans forever even if he had never
done anything but portrayed the love
Lauren Wesley in the 1987 classic The
Princess Bride as he wished
Ellis's role isn't so lovable this time
around he plays mayor Klein previously
revealed and promotional materials for
stranger things 3 as the shady driving
force behind the construction of the new
star court mall character descriptions
from the new season have described the
character as quote handsome slick and
sleazy your classic 80s politician more
concerned with his own image than with
the people of the small town he governs
so on top of all the other monstrous
activity it looks like season 3 will
have something of a political angle at
work also joining the cast this season
is Jake Busey as Bruce a writer for the
Hawkins post but he's no crusading
journalist seeking to expose mayor
clients corruption his character
description pegs him as a man of
questionable morals with a sixth sense
of humor we see only the briefest of
shots featuring the character in the
trailer and he looks sick alright he
appears to be standing in the hall
inside some kind of research facility
most likely the Hawkins National
Laboratory that's connected to all the
town's interdimensional goings-on
he's unkempt with his tie undone smeared
with blood and sporting a twisted smile
his appearance is the first
of several clues which may hint at
Hawkins's big problem this year there
seems to be some kind of infection going
around one which looks to have also
spread to Billy heart row everyone's
least favorite evil stepbrother Lucas's
sister Erica was a comedic bright spot
of stranger thanks to but her role was a
small one this season we're going to
find out a little more about her not the
least of which is the fact that
apparently the prospect of coming
face-to-face with zombified townspeople
and horrific spider looking monsters
doesn't pre-curved in the least in one
shot she's seen commando crawling
through an air duct in full die hard
mode wearing a makeshift miner's helmet
made out of flashlights of tape she only
appeared in four episodes of the second
season but it looks like Erica will be a
little closer to the action this time
around
joining her big brother and his friends
and their unsupervised monster fighting
activities previously released
promotional materials for this season
have leaned heavily on cryptic imagery
and phrases like the line when blue and
yellow meet in the West a phrase which
is turned up in a short teaser trailer
and hidden in Morse code in a
behind-the-scenes book what could this
be referring to there are a couple of
possibilities one shot in the new
trailer features eleven all alone and
wearing a yellow shirt standing on the
beach as an eerie light illuminates the
night sky behind her and to the left is
a blue blue body of water could it be
that a pivotal point occurs here it's
also been pointed out that in the star
court mall announcement teaser released
earlier in 2018 the hands of the clock
on the malls face also happened to be
yellow and blue indicating that
something serious might go down when the
hands meet the season will conclude with
an episode entitled the Battle of Star
courts and there's more than one shot in
the trailer indicating that Hawkins's
new mall is indeed going to be the scene
of some serious trouble
1-shot C Steve Dustin Erica and newcomer
Robin a co-worker of Steve's at the
foodcourt ice cream shop barricaded
behind a set of the mall sliding doors
another shot shows the whole gang
battered bloody and looking ready to
take on whatever adversary has invaded
their new shopping centre we also seem
to have gotten a bit of clarification on
the title of episode 3 the case of the
missing lifeguard
and early sequins reveals that Billy has
a new job as a lifeguard at the local
pool and he exchanges a flirty glance
with a cute co-worker who passes by him
this same girl is seen very briefly in
that closing montage seemingly being
dragged into the depths of the
upside-down as Billy watches helplessly
could this be the incident which leads
to the onset of Billy's unfortunate
condition either way it looks like the
evils of the upside down are once again
making an effort to break through into
the real world and 11 seems to once
again be the only person who can stop it
the powerful psychic is shown getting
sucked into the upside-down confronting
some kind of force in that shot on the
beach and standing blindfolded with a
slight nosebleed in front of a freezer
chock full of the one thing she's never
been able to resist Eggo waffles but
most tellingly the spots final moments
see her in that same yellow shirt base
full of righteous anger nose bleeding
like a faucet facing off against that
grotesque spider thing let's hope she
gets to have at least one a go first
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]